ces championnats du monde ont lieu tous
les 15 ans en france 17 pays
s'affrontent de l'afrique du sud aux
états unis en passant par le japon
l'équipe de france compte huit hommes et
deux femmes championne du monde dans
toutes les catégories il y a deux ans au
texas
les français sont dans les favoris une
équipe plutôt de jeunes par rapport aux
autres équipes donc des gens
particulièrement motivés qui vole avec
beaucoup de de tonicité
on voit des vols très spectaculaire
on a une qualité en france c'est qu'on
vole très près des juges en de ce fait
on essaie de lutter énormément quand le
vent est d'être toujours très présents
la reconnaissance pré-vol indispensable
avant de décoller baptiste fait de la
compétition depuis six ans ce que ce
passionné recherche avant tout dans les
airs c'est cette sensation à nulle autre
pareille
alliant adrénaline et douleur on peut
monter jusqu'à 10 g 10 g c'est-à-dire
dix fois la gravité c'est à dire qu'on
va peser notre poids par dix pas
seulement nous mais aussi l'avion à dire
que cet avion fait 580 kg j'en fais 75
on va dire donc ça veut dire que tout
cet ensemble va peser six fois son poids
la préparation comprend aussi cette
petite danse un moment incontournable
avant d'entrer dans l'avion c'est en
fonction de comment on le ressent nous
voilà il ya vraiment il faut que ça il
faut qu'on s'imagine dans l'avion il
faut qu'on se mentalise le fait qu'on
est en train de piloter aux commandes de
l'avion répète le vol depuis le
décollage presque jusqu'à l'atterrissage
on répète tout ce qui se passera
réellement dans l'avion vous avez
jusqu'au 29 août pour allez vous mettre
la tête dans les nuages un petit
préambule
rien que pour vous
on